[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on ressent effectivement
une forte augmentation des prix
notamment ce qui est visible c'est
vraiment à la pompe quand on fait le
plein avant bah 60 euros on avait
effectivement de quoi faire 600 700 km
maintenant c'est 90 euros donc il y a
effectivement une réflexion qui s'impose
avant de avant de faire un déplacement
de toute manière en règle générale on
essaie de faire attention aussi donc en
priorise effectivement tout ce qui est
nécessaire et tout ce qui est superflu
on fait plus attention on continue d'en
faire mais je pense qu'on peut établir
son budget raisonnablement
je pense que l'état de refaire un petit
effort
c'est déjà apprécié ce qu'il faut le
carburant il devrait voir un peu comment
remédier à ça j'ai vu qu'hier il y avait
une augmentation paradoxale ce RSA les
aides de la famille pourquoi ne pas
basculer également sur le panier de la
ménagère avec ce genre d'herbe
il s'agit de sciences humaines les
sciences humaines font référence à des
comportements des individus qui peuvent
être ces comportements qui peuvent
devenir aléatoires imprévisibles parfois
même un peu
contradictoire on a pour faire simple
deux catégories d'individus en économie
on considère qu'il y a des offres et des
demandeurs parce qu'on a un marché un
marché c'est de l'offre et de la demande
et ces individus qui sont soit d'un côté
soit de l'autre du marché ont des
intérêts divergents on comprend bien que
le vendeur a l'intention de vendre le
plus cher possible l'acheteur celui qui
côté demande du marché à l'intention
d'acheter le moins cher possible bien
évidemment pour ses intérêts mais ils ne
peuvent pas le faire de façon infinie
ils ont chacun des contraintes le
vendeur à la contrainte de la
concurrence qui va lui permettre de
s'arrêter un jour et de pas faire des
prix excessifs le consommateur lui a à
la contrainte de son revenu de son
salaire et donc ces contraintes et dans
participe à ce que le marché permet par
confrontation de ces offres et de ses
demandes de trouver un prix qui va
satisfaire tout le monde ce qu'on
appelle un prix d'équilibre et qui rend
compatible c'est besoin et ses attentes
parfois divergentes on a donc des prix
d'équilibre que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
que les prix semblent un peu sortir des
sortir des sentiers sortir de cet
équilibre pourquoi et bien parce qu'il y
a des événements et parfois les
événements ne sont pas toujours
prévisibles il y a des événements qui
par définition ne peuvent pas être
prévues puisqu’imprévisibles ou en tout
cas pas être correctement prévu comme on
a moult exemple aujourd'hui moult
exemple aujourd'hui on a la guerre en
Ukraine on a la crise sanitaire quand il
y a un phénomène une guerre l'économie
tourner au ralenti elle produit moins il
y a des pénuries et la pénurie fait que
les prix vont monter et finalement que
se passe-t-il et bien sur le marché on
va avoir des vendeurs qui vont tendance
à auront tendance à monter les prix
parce qu'ils ont moins de produits à
vendre mais qu'ils doivent rester
finalement pérenne leur activité doit
rester pérenne et des consommateurs qui
ne vont plus accepter ou ne vont plus
pouvoir accepter de tel prix qui sont
plus importants et ils vont donc sortir
ou être sortis du marché ces
consommateurs de sorte que finalement
ils vont être victimes d'une baisse de
leur pouvoir d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat de leur salaire ou de
leurs revenus et globalement dans
l'économie on constate et on mesure le
pouvoir d'achat de ce qu'on appelle le
revenu mais du point de vue global on va
parler de revenus disponibles bruts
revenus disponible brut pourquoi
disponible parce que c'est le revenu
qu'on calcule déduction faite des
prélèvements fiscaux et sociaux
prélèvement fiscaux et sociaux entendés
par là les impôts et les cotisations
sociales et c'est ce revenu dont peut
disposer on va dire le ménage les
individus pour consommer ou
accessoirement quand c'est possible s'il
le souhaite épargner donc il a cet
arbitrage consommation épargne le revenu
disponible brut en France est sur une
tendance longue sur 50 ans on a ce qu'on
appelle une baisse tendancielle du
revenu disponible brut si on regarde
ailleurs alors nos voisins proches ou
éloignés on s'aperçoit qu'il y a plutôt
une tendance à l'amélioration à des
gains de pouvoir d'achat pour les
États-Unis ils sont trois fois plus
importants ces gains sont pour les
États-Unis trois fois plus important
qu'en France ou le gain de pouvoir
d'achat du revenu disponible brut est à
hauteur de 8 et quelques pourcents 8,3%
très précisément c'est moins que les
États-Unis mais c'est plus que chez nos
amis et voisins italiens puisque pour
eux il y a une perte de pouvoir d'achat
de l'ordre de 5,3 %. voilà pour le
pouvoir d'achat du revenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]